el presidente andrés manuel lópez
obrador anticipó que va a plantear a su
homólogo de eeuu joe biden en el marco
de la próxima cumbre climática que se
amplíe a centroamérica uno de sus
programas estrella sembrando vida en qué
consiste sembrando vida bueno pues en un
monto mensual de 250 dólares a los
campesinos de las zonas pobres del país
para que siembren árboles frutales y
maderables combatir así la pobreza y
ordenar los flujos migratorios
impidiendo que los campesinos vayan a
eeuu por falta de trabajo no es la
primera vez que es sembrando vida
pretende ser exportado en junio de 2019
el canciller marcelo ebrard había dicho
que se invertirían 100 millones de
dólares en guatemala honduras y el
salvador para que se aplica y sembrando
vida y se frenen los flujos migratorios
sin embargo tras la extinción de los
fideicomisos en mexico no se tiene claro
si se materializaron esas inversiones
además la auditoría superior de la
federación ha señalado fallas en este
programa como padrones de beneficiarios
incompletos o retrasos de hasta 11 meses
en el pago a los participantes de
sembrando vida el punto se prevé que sea
tratado en la próxima visita que ya
anuncio kamala harris vicepresidenta de
eeuu andrés manuel lópez obrador ha
dicho que actualmente se siembran un
millón de hectáreas y se da empleo a 400
mil personas se pretende que si se
amplía a centroamérica se siembre en 3
millones de hectáreas y haya empleo para
un millón 300 mil campesinos